all right let's get to Friday feedback
Friday I like to take a look at what
folks have been saying you know it we
get five or six thousand different
comments a day across email YouTube Tick
Tock Etc it's impossible to look at all
of them but I like to take a look at a
sampling and see some of the criticisms
that people are making some of the
praise and some of the questions that
people are asking so let's start first
and foremost let's just get this out of
the way okay
392 Chapa on YouTube says who is paying
you
this is a question rarely asked in good
faith it usually implies that some
nefarious forces are funding this
program or that I only am saying the
things I'm saying because someone is
giving me money or whatever the case may
be so let me clarify we fund this
program
through three General categories number
one memberships people who just sign up
on the website so like 392 Chapa could
just as easily be one of the people
paying me as anybody else that's one of
our funding sources secondly
the plat some of the platforms we're on
provide ad revenue for the little ads
that show up like before a video or in
between videos and that includes
um YouTube that includes Facebook that
includes more recently Tick Tock uh not
Instagram okay so that's another funding
source and then lastly direct ad sales
that we do so like when you hear me
talking about a product or service the
that's who pays me there's no big
millionaire billionaire donor there's no
DNC money I'm not even a Democrat I
don't know why the DNC would pay me or
if I tell you things that I like about
Democrats and things I don't not clear
what why there would be an incentive
there
um and that's basically the bottom line
that's it there's nothing sketchy or
secret going on uh and one of the great
things about that way of being funded is
there is no one person that can even
attempt to hold money over our heads to
get me to say or not say whatever
there's no single Advertiser that's so
big that they could come and say hey we
really don't like what you're saying
about X or Y or whatever because I would
say listen we we have many advertisers
and we aside from the fact that I would
never do that even financially like you
you don't really have me over a barrel
same thing with our audience members one
person who's a member says David I will
pull my three dollars a month
if you don't take back that thing you
said it's there's just no leverage okay
there's no leverage so that's who is
paying me and by the way organizations
like the daily wire and others actually
do have the big donors organizations
like Turning Point USA have the big
donors focus on them there's no exciting
story about who's paying us
Scotty Rhoden and Scotty says I know you
won't
but I feel a ton of us want you to run
for president well Scotty I legally
cannot run for president of the United
States I was not born
in the United States I was born in
Argentina and at least for now maybe
Arnold Schwarzenegger will get the law
changed at some point I'm not sure I
would not legally be allowed to run for
president so I hate to if if it is true
that there are a ton of us that want me
to run for president as Scotty says I
hate to disappoint but it's just not
going to be possible under current law
John tool
says I wouldn't vote for Chris Christie
but it is nice to hear a republican
sound more like they used to again it's
just nice to see a republican talking on
an adult level again as of now Christy
really does have the strongest campaign
start on the Republican side hands down
agree completely it's not even close
it's not even close Vivek ramaswami's
campaign is just a mess it's like a
verbal verbal ink plot uh Nikki Haley's
campaign is a joke Tim Scott's campaign
is laughable Mike Pence's couldn't
possibly have less energy okay you go
through all of them then you get to Ron
DeSantis he's just a complete and total
disaster in terms of his campaign focus
on anti-woke his inability to in any
remotely charismatic way actually go
against the guy who's leading which is
Trump then we get Trump okay you got
Trump it's Christy it's CR and I am not
voting for Christy I'm not a republican
I'm it's just if I had to vote for a
republican it's so obviously Chris
Christie and John is finding uh that
he's coming away with the same
perspective
Bruton rode on Reddit
says there's a growing number of people
in my community and others believing
conservative propaganda that Democrats
are the party of slavery and it's
working why aren't we trying to stop
this yes I know Democrats in the 1800s
did form the Confederacy but we also
know pushing the narrative in 2023 that
Democrats are the true racist party
without full and proper context is
clearly agenda based and not a good
faith discussion my question is why
isn't more being done to combat this I'm
guessing most people don't not seeing
how big of a problem this is becoming in
the black community well listen a couple
things first of all I don't know that
it's becoming a big problem in the black
community because if black folks were
being tricked into thinking that the
modern democratic party is the party of
slavery you wouldn't see such high
levels of support for Democratic
candidates from the black community
black folks and Jewish folks are the two
groups that most vote Democratic in the
United States States and my belief is
that if either of those groups were
falling for the lie that the Democrats
of the Confederacy or the Democrats of
2023 you wouldn't see those levels of
support that being said yes I do think
it would be better to more strongly
disabuse people of the notion that there
is a connection between Democrats of the
Civil War era and Democrats of 2023 in
order to explain this you do have to go
into some history about party
realignments and different things I I
think that it's worth doing part of it
would be great to do
in school at the educational level and
prevent people from Ever falling for
this stuff in the first place but the
one part I take issue with this viewer
is that I'm not seeing the evidence that
it is really convincing too many people
um doesn't mean we don't want to combat
it but it doesn't seem like as big an
issue as this person is worried about
Chris Ortiz comments why don't what what
you don't get Bud is the reason the
economy is so strong is because of what
Trump did in his first term and I guess
you forget how high inflation really is
I love guys like you you point at every
bad point of a person but offer no new
insight I bet you call yourself an
independent typical but I may be wrong
well listen I am not a democrat or a
republican in that sense I'm independent
but I don't pretend to be a Centrist or
anything like that I'm on the left but
when it comes to economic matters I try
to remove Politics as much as possible
and just give you the analysis based on
the data the empirical analysis there is
no evidence I can find that the current
economic indicators are what they are
because of what Donald Trump did in his
first term however Chris I also so don't
go around putting the credit for the
economy being what it is squarely on the
shoulders of Joe Biden presidents in
general make tweaks that can affect the
general direction of the economy but
much of what is going on is bigger than
the United States and it's certainly
bigger than what's in the Oval Office
the point I make about the Biden economy
is that there is a group that says Biden
doesn't deserve a second term
because the economy is so terrible and
there is no empirical database case that
you can make that proves the economy is
terrible that's my point Vinnie wrote in
and says I find it crazy that DeSantis
is now running unquote destroying the
left and the media acts like this is
normal politics and not fascism imagine
if a Democrat ran on getting rid of all
conservatism that would be on 24 7 loop
on Fox and any other right-wing Outlet
this guy is full on anti-democracy and
nobody seems to care 100 listen that
applies to so many stories imagine if
Barack Obama was indicted on 37 counts
and it turned out that he obstructed an
attempt to return classified documents
uh to their uh rightful
custodians that a server room was
flooded by draining the pool at his
Resort that he had boxes of classified
documents stacked up around his toilet
just imagine how this the coverage would
be different from the right and
similarly Rhonda Santa said if I I will
destroy the leftism if I become
president
if Joe Biden said we will destroy
conservatism
they would be saying this guy is an
authoritarian fascist he's dangerous uh
all of the things that we know they try
to say at any opportunity Vinnie is
completely right there is a stunning
double standard out there about this
issue Dennis says about Ron DeSantis he
is stopping homosexuality in school
not Banning educational books I don't
know if Dennis actually means this but
you realize that if what Ron DeSantis is
trying to do is to stop homosexuality in
schools that that's extraordinarily
disturbing what does it mean to stop
homosexuality because Dennis isn't
saying stopping discussion of
homosexuality in school
then it seems to be saying stopping
homosexuality in school you're going to
ban gay people from what going to school
teaching what are you talking about
Dennis this is someone who's trying to
defend DeSantis and actually makes it
look even worse
lastly on the trans and drag issue
Richard Martin said if you want to raise
your kid to be a freak Show moved to
another country don't put that stuff in
the school system and try to screw up
other kids heads if you want your kid to
be a freak show that you're a business
to take him down to a gay bar throwing
in the door let them have them and leave
a note on his back saying this week drop
off when you're done with them have fun
simple solves the problem that is one
sentence no punctuation and it is not
even worthy of a response other than to
remind you
this and this person also has a Jack
Daniels bottle as their profile picture
this is what we are up against
and as I've said before
we're not going to convince Richard
Martin that he's wrong in any reasonable
amount of time
and so what we have to do instead is
activate people who don't plan to vote
that's the much more direct and
efficient path towards trying to win
elections really sad stuff going on in
this country we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today just a reminder that
we will be off on Monday the federal
holiday Juneteenth I hope everybody has
a great Monday uh whether you're working
or not we will be off and then uh we'll
be back the rest of the week all right
everybody great bonus show today sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted again indict it again